-Thanks for having me.
It's been a while.
-It's been a while.
-It has.
-How old is baby now?
-Baby is 3 1/2.
-Wow! Is that right?
-Baby's a toddler.
Baby's not a baby.
-Baby's not a baby anymore.
-Yeah, she's huge.
-3 1/2.
-Are you into "Paw Patrol"?
-Oh.
-I'm sorry, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Are you into all those shows?
-Ah, "Paw Patrol."
Yeah, no, we are.
We're really, really deep, deep,
deep into "Paw Patrol."
-Have you done "Dora"?
-Yeah, but it's like
toddler crack, isn't it?
-No, yeah, no.
-I mean, which is kind of
a good thing, because,
you know, you go, "Okay."
It's been Saturday night,
and maybe you've had
a couple of more glasses of wine
than you should have,
and Sunday morning,
"Paw Patrol"...
-...is the best thing
that ever existed
in the history of the world.
-Absolutely amazing.
-Yes, exactly.
Thank you, "Paw Patrol."
-But if you don't have
the hangover, it's just...
So we don't just have, like --
'Cause we have
to act it out, as well.
-Oh, I didn't know that.
-Yeah, yeah, constantly,
'cause it's the bathtime thing.
We have bath toys,
"Paw Patrol" is in the bath.
I mean, it's everywhere,
but it's in the bath.
And she'll
only let me be Rubble.
And, okay, the parents --
parents in the audience
would understand this,
but Rubble's rubbish.
-Oh, no, come on, now!
No, come on.
-I want to be Skye!
She has to be Skye.
You know, but she will only
let me be Rubble.
And then,
she tells me off about it.
"No, don't do that.
No, he doesn't talk like that."
I'm like,
"I get paid for this."
[ Laughter ]
-"Mommy is a professional actor!
Hello!"
-Mommy knows what she's doing.
-"This is the way
Rubble talks from now on."
-She won't have it.
-Oh, gosh.
Oh, get used to that.
My kids are over the --
I mean, they're super
into "Paw Patrol" now,
but I'm into it now.
-Are you?
-Yeah, I'm like into the plot
lines and all the stuff, yeah.
-Yeah, it's deep.
It's really deep.
-It's really, really deep.
Well, congrats on baby,
and I know you're married
and your husband is a musician.
-Yes.
-Are you musical?
-No.
-You're not?
-No, no.
-I always thought you were.
-No, I mean, I played the flute
when I was at school.
-Hey, there you go.
-Yeah, there you go, thanks.
I mean, I probably
can't anymore, but, no, no.
-No musical talent at all?
No hidden talent?
-No. Oh, no, what?
Oh, yes, there is one.
[ Laughter ]
-There might be one, maybe?
-There's a very special one,
yes.
-I heard that maybe one.
-Yeah, I can play my teeth.
[ Laughter ]
-Now how did you
come up with this?
How did you know
that you had this talent?
-Well, there was a boy at school
when I was about 7 or 8,
and he went
on a talent show on TV,
so he was, like,
the coolest person ever,
and he played his teeth,
so everybody at my school
was like, "Wow, that's cool."
So everybody from that school,
I think,
can probably play their teeth.
So, obsessively
playing their teeth.
-I mean, I don't know.
I mean, the audience
might not want to hear
a little sample --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
We would love it if you could
just give us a taste.
We'll be very quiet.
-Okay. I mean, what do you want?
-All right,
maybe just give me a classic.
-Okay.
I mean, classic is
"Raindrops Keep Falling
on Your Head,"
'cause I think that's what
he played on the talent show.
So, like,
that's what I first learned.
Would you like that?
-I would love that.
♪♪
Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You even did
"Nothing's bothering me."
-Thanks.
You even did
"Nothing's bothering me."
-Of course.
-That is musical talent!
That's fantastic.
Could you do like a newer song,
like a more modern song?
-Yeah, I mean, yeah.
What would you like?
I can do anything you like.
-Could you do "Despacito"?
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
Uh, a moment..
[ Humming ]
Okay.
♪♪
-Oh, my God!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Should write an album!
-Thank you.
-That's a record album!
-Yes!
-That's fantastic!
That's an album right there.
I would totally buy that.
-I can't believe my husband
hasn't put me in a band yet.
-I mean, what is he thinking?
Yeah, please.
-Yeah, I know.
-I read something, also,
about you that --
it said that you only
watch your movies once, if that.
-Yeah, if that.
Yes, yeah.
-Why?
Just 'cause you don't
want to watch yourself?
I mean, you're great.
-Thank you.
No, yeah, I don't know.
It's just wei-- It's weird.
It's like
hearing your own voice.
It's like, you know --
I don't know.
And I only see the bad bits,
so I'm like,
"Oh. Why did I do that?"
-So, when you see this photo,
don't you go,
"I was in 'Love Actually.'
This is a great --
I have to watch this movie."
-Do you know what the only thing
that I really remember
from doing "Love Actually" --
I was 17 --
and this -- this --
I got the biggest zit of my life
when we were
shooting this scene.
And this scene was like --
It's the important one,
isn't it?
-This is where
you're watching the wedding.
-Yeah, so it was literally --
it was like another head
growing out of my head.
And I was only in the film --
It's a small part.
I was only on it for two weeks,
and, like, the chances
of getting this extra head...
And so they went in,
and they tried to cover it,
and they tried to light it,
and there was nothing
they could do,
so the hat went on.
[ Laughter ]
-Is that the reason
why you're wearing the hat?
-Yeah, that's the reason
for the hat.
-Wow! I thought
it was just a fashion choice.
-I mean, it was lucky
it wasn't anywhere else, though,
'cause I don't know
what we would've done.
-You're wearing a scarf
around your whole head.
Oh, my gosh.
That's good triv.
-Yeah.
-I love that.
Every time I watch it now,
I'll think of that.
And I'll watch it every year.
Trust me, I love it.
Let's talk about
"The Aftermath."
-Yes.
-What a great film.
A cool choice of a film,
I would say.
'Cause I've seen "War Room"
and stuff like that,
but this deals
with a different subject.
-Yeah, it does.
It sort of deals with
the direct aftermath
of World War II and kind of --
I think it asks the questions
about how do you get over
a catastrophic conflict
like that
and how do you rebuild yourself,
personally,
but, also, how do nations
rebuild themselves?
So it's kind of
a story about that.
So, it's a tragedy.
It's also a love triangle,
but it's kind of, I think,
a story of redemption and hope.